ladies and gentlemen I'd like to say how
very happy and thrilled I am to have
been told to be here tonight after
seeing so many very wonderful talents on
this stage for the past hour and a half
or so I am very proud very privileged to
be a part and a member of show business
and happy to be with MCA the owners
before I forget I would like to make
mention of the fact that President
Eisenhower was supposed to be with us
tonight to make a speech but
unfortunately as you know the pressures
the president has are pretty tremendous
and he is now going through a very very
difficult task of trying very hard to
make the big three meeting he of course
is very anxious to appear but he's
having trouble getting Frank Sinatra and
Sammy Davis jr. you see therefore they
can next be seen in separate tables now
I am actually should I take the fall now
I am actually very delighted to be on
the show tonight with the gentleman that
I had he appeared with before mr. Bob
Hope and this is truly a very very
magnificent man he's a gentleman who was
not only a great credit to our
profession but he is also a very
patriotic man and I am very very happy
and thrilled to announce that in case of
war he will release the Armed Forces for
active duty
I'll wait I think that it was swell of
him actually to do this and the pride of
the show I saw Bob saying backstage
talking to Mort Sahl
who is a very very wonderful entertainer
and I suspected Bob is planning to take
a trip to the moon and he just wants to
be filled in by someone who's been there
of course I'm only kidding the Shah was
a fantastic performer and I enjoyed
watching him tremendously and he's very
shrewd and very sharp as a matter of
fact if you notice he works in a sweater
tonight he didn't but he usually works
in the sweater and I think he remembers
that the way Lana Turner was discovered
of course there is quite a difference in
the bill he's taller now of course I
would like very much to make mention the
fact that we are getting to a point in
the program where so many people are
anxious and of course a comedian can
stand up here and do an awful lot of
talking an awful lot of jokes prepared
material as you know and you try so hard
to watch this thing go by but at the
same time I don't want to take up a lot
of time with it I would like very much
to go on because we only have another
four days and it's so important to get
to the big awards you see this woman is
drunk down front and I can't concentrate
actually we would like to present the
best art Direction award and of course
the art direction is it art direction
because I missed a spot is it thank you
for I'm sorry I woke you to present the
art direction award here are two
brilliant actors who are closely
associated with art he's the Vincent
Price who owns a collection of art that
is to be envied and the man who envies
it mr. Eddie Albert if you please
art direction of Vinnie you know while
we're here I got a sneaking direction
with a favorite performers of these art
directors yeah I didn't want to bring
that up Andy but I felt the same thing
some of the pictures we're in the
audience seems to prefer to look at the
says yeah they might be doing that now
so let's read the nominees all right
nominees for the best achievement in art
direction are Auntie Mame art direction
by Malcolm Burt set decoration by George
James Hopkins Bell book and candle art
direction by Kerry O'Dell set that
decoration by new ideas a certain smile
art direction by Lila wheeler and John
de Cure set decoration by Walter M scott
and paul s fox GT our decoration by
William a Horning and Preston Ames set
decoration by Howard Ferrara and Henry
Bumstead set decoration by Sam comer and
Frank McKelvey now the winner is Gigi
William Harding
accompanying mr. Preston Eames and
accepting for William a Horning
mr. Hollis Peter
hands Peters will accept the award for
mr. horny come on a real care for the
winners ladies and gentlemen